okay now hold on somebody has a comment
yes Lal Jay in New Hampshire
hi Jimmy hello hi kind of little Asian
like a dad but like you look ridiculous
I like you ever tell him to wear your
shoes could be better for sure like a
great idea
I love this idea okay that's so simple
and so easy rock words are great for
casual whatever I like am sure she's
making good points yes she is making
good points
blessed by actually the first but to
build Jimmy up by tearing me down makes
no sense because you've never seen me on
stage that's one where have you seen
live wherever you see me where assume oh
y'all be there next week why you go out
that late problem is sometimes you go
for the fence when you should only be
going for a single and I went for the
fence and I struck out I didn't hit a
homerun an hour and you you called it
out and and that was good for you
now wait you soon and I looked at each
other when you said that too so it was
like we thought well I knew I was
bombing as it was coming out okay you
know what I mean and not even have a
follow-up like I usually do right when
you saw me in Boston you were at a
laughs laughs Boston dr. Klein I'm here
he's had to show me a couple of
different people and it was a couple
years ago what I was still drinking and
I I'll be honest I don't really
are you sober yes sir six years good for
you good for you now do you do you ever
listen to this in a meeting maybe why
tear someone down to build yourself up
we're not tearing him down we're trying
to help him we're not we're not tearing
him down we're we're trying to help him
that's what it wasn't even about me we
were just talking about your rings you
know I got a little ring he was saying
that you are not fit to give gym fashion
advice because I look ridiculous that's
what she was but here's the deal I
didn't have rings when you saw me a
couple years ago I didn't have anything
so what's that but you do now are you
married are you married
hold on that's not relevant she's saying
she doesn't like your look down now LJ
do you think that rich looks ludicrous
[Laughter]
do you what is it LJ about rich
specifically is it the hats
is it not today but she's not looking at
me right now all the time I love my hat
but the hats do look stupid no they
don't I get ya man you know what it's 50
here's the thing in life folks yes she
doesn't like your aunt like 4x
oh that's very nice yeah boobs
maybe we supposed to shirtless picture
so everybody could see no maybe later
rings that would look good sneakers
never yeah come on put the other ring on
though you can have the rings on yeah oh
my god you literally look like the
spider in it rich you gotta put you have
to do it for the photo it's crazy not to
[Music]
thank you thanks for the call she likes
all of this put the ring on
rich is now standing in the studio so
much it's rubbish to show you down the
hall okay you don't look bad it's you
look stupid what you know he means from
the waist up Jesus rich as no sir I
can't believe hold on a second
he's posing he isn't good again
certainly does out the other way for the
angle I can see around from the side to
turn the other way rich the way you just
work you look good you look great rich
yeah yeah this picture by the way look
at Fosters I wouldn't do that I'm sure I
may have just had the best I ever heard
I honestly uh well I don't want to turn
it to him so I actually I really was
trying to find a bad picture this one
boss's face is a little enraging I'll
post it down can we uh can we use the
photo that we took of us to set up a
grinder account yes please do that
say yes and then we'll visit will visit
later no hold on Travis I'm posting when
you tell me if you think this would be
the one to do that well who already has
it installed I guess send us the photo
we'll take the going over photos down I
can't sorry guys I'm posting one of us
it only took us 38 minutes to get to get
that shirt off I appreciate it rich I
appreciate you doing that
you look good with the rings and
everything wait wait give me a month
when I shoot my special yeah how [ __ ]
ripped I'm gonna be yeah cuz you have
gained a little weight
really muscle it's not much it's a
little knob here than it usually they
never know it went down and ran off you
used to have a stomach like a Sakana
[Laughter]
I'll admit this is a good one excellent
this is a good turn chewie chewie tell
Voss when he gets back I think so he's
got it we the reason we were like in
that first hour looking at our phones
and doing all this stuff yeah we put we
put rich on Grindr yeah there's a
grinder account with Kyle 57 the photo
that rich just took with all the radio
branding Photoshop Photoshop that of it
yeah and he looks really handsome yeah
he has no shirt on yeah so he's already
got a swipe he already has a swipe which
is really really great
yeah I'm very promising young fellow is
that from a young guy 27 did you write
anything in the ad that we see we push
to something in the ad
well yeah you gotta write like about me
and stuff about me I'm 57 year old
versatile bottom well you know as funny
you mentioned because they did ask
position uh-huh yeah do this cool man
yeah no we were just congratulations by
the way
celebrating cuz a mutual friend of ours
just got first white his first white
which is pretty cool on Grindr which is
awesome who Kyle Kyle winder a few
swipes my friend Kyle got a swipe under
do you know Grindr
of course he does no it's not a swipe
it's uh it's uh ya know it's like it's
like tinder but uh it's for is it just
for men or is it forgave men or gateway
um I don't know I've spent almost no
time on that I don't know yeah no I
haven't I obviously haven't spent any
time you see he does he work here Kyle
no he does not work out here no no do
you have can you pull up a Grindr
profile on the can you know what I
resent what about if I did it if you are
good you don't know who's coming to your
place you know what I mean
so do you want to rate his picture I
would love like in the room okay
[ __ ] loaves do you have can you pull up
Kyle's Grindr profile on your phone okay
why don't you come in and then where you
could pull up profiles
yeah if they're in the area because
we're just looking at Kyle funky in an
argument elites I'm like if you could
come in and maybe show it to me and I'll
describe it and then Jim and then Voss
okay I want to look at it you wouldn't
describe show it to me first and I'll
describe what I see and then to Jim and
he'll describe and then to Voss and
he'll describe okay Wow
so he's a he's a pretty handsome guy I
want to just look at the photo right now
he's a he's a pretty handsome guy bad I
thought he I thought he'd be younger
yeah but I could see where this is this
is pretty popular I don't know I don't
know exactly what else to say about
anything look at yeah yeah Jim and it
blast me why anything probably better at
describing you know um he looks kind of
like a like almost like a daddy a smug
oh the kind of ugly
daddy look I don't know the language um
you know just showing it off and it's
kind of like he's almost ready to hug
somebody like a young lad who was to
show up he's gonna be embraced by those
arms like like get in here and snuggle
up so you're not you're not surprised
he's popular no not at all I mean I
don't know what guys what kind of guys
would like him but I would say he's more
of a daddy okay so maybe like maybe like
a young cub would like him probably or a
twink maybe a twink yeah yeah that'd be
perfect
alright you want to give it to rich you
tell what do you think Kyle
you haven't said you don't know Kyle
right now he doesn't know okay so this
is cold okay you think are you [ __ ]
you take that off yeah I'm sure you
can't put that on there I'll get do you
understand what this is gonna do stupid
thing it's gonna be come on are you
[ __ ] now all right are you kidding me
my wife will kill me I'm married now
you're not real I got kids
oh that's not on Grindr it is but no one
thinks it's really a real profile wait
does rich want to respond to the guy
first
do it respond to the one swipe again
what'd she look like all right take it
off I made them change the name they
want to put ranch I got three [ __ ]
kids yeah you're gonna get any that's
the point you don't want anymore and
this is a way to do it yeah it's not
over it's not real kids like this five
what what happened you send me a screen
cap don't say his name
okay just it just isn't looking we oh my
god Kyle just got a message a private
message weather say it says it's it's
9:18 a.m. the message says like fisting
reply yes hey I'm serious
take it off yeah if you wants it off you
gotta take it off yeah but it's a funny
bit I get it
I and you could have somebody that would
fist you couldn't cool yeah I know
somebody elfish me if they see that on
there she already thinks I'm gay that's
Rich's issue there's already too much
suspicion and you got it take it off I'm
sure type of the screen cap up on
Twitter just not if he wants it off just
so people can play along do you mind I
don't want that rich I try to be a team
player if he doesn't want to take it
yeah there's no reason to put the screen
cap up by Davis
I mean look Brenda he may change his
mind save the screen cabin - we won't
post it right right and we've got the
profile say we'll take it down what's
the profile say do we have what does it
say goodbye oh yeah we have the bio hang
on yeah which is a good picture you it's
not real together put me on put it on
tinder Joe's grind don't it'll be worse
why I don't look how fat I am Tinder's
work I don't care how
tenders not tenders worse yeah 10 years
worse because you'd wind up actually to
be actually a bunch of girls like
whatever the people really are you're
gonna possibly hook up with [ __ ] sent
you messages
[Music]
that's the bio say the bio bio short
okay what's a tattooed golfer slash
Archer enjoys high fashion and clean
nails I like that
height five to warious come on five to
180 in your two golfer if I type
muscular what was that character that
would dwarf on golf Denis used to walk
yeah Connolly's character yeah we're on
his knees all right I gotta call my
lawyer take it off
pronouns he/him/his pronouns to so
people know what to address them as
position bottom I'm definitely not a
body all right so we got one thing wrong
yeah
tribes daddy-o I was right what do
tribes mean just like where you fall I
know
relationship status open relationship
see okay we were disrespectful to your
relationship looking for right now are
you [ __ ] gay you got a little
negative here's the thing yeah I come in
here right I don't do good radio I'm
trying to cut away from that whole oh na
I'm not the bunt of your [ __ ] little
skits first of all you but no no no I
got it to fully address you know you're
you're fairly invalid point okay when no
one is saying that you're the bunt of
the skit no one's saying whose pictures
up there
and we still can't go back and grab
audio that we just had this new system
[ __ ] blows Oh Paul all systems gone
but the new system hasn't been
implemented these [ __ ] yeah no one's
staying at the bunch of the joke we're
not here to be the bunch of the joke but
we're here to have fun
no you're the only one we would've done
the same thing to Troy yeah yeah Troy
there's gonna have to be kids and a wife
but no your kids knowing at you it's
it's a radio thing when they put you on
grinder who cares listen when I lost
when I gave out my [ __ ] uh password
yeah okay and then all this gay stuff
came on the internet within five minutes
my daughter text me or email me said
what's going on daddy somebody was doing
stuff on your Facebook but they don't
know who's doing this they don't know
hey this is a skit from a radio show
city you gave out your password on the
radio don't know this one now like no
one knows they go looking for she's
going under a fake name people know me a
fake name rich do you want us to delete
it I'm telling you yeah he wants you
gotta take it of course but he's winking
when he says yes no no first of all at
least you see who you match with today
no no not at five to 180 it's 9:30 in
the morning and you're already have
opportunities you know I don't think I
don't think okay so your hands these
like I can take people will screenshot
this we need to take it down we're not
gonna get any better than right away a
night wearing off right now we're not
gonna get any better than a 9:30 request
for a fisting anyway so where does the
guy you should find out before we take
it up no we're taking it off you know
people just this guy can hurt no it's
not it can't it won't hurt the fish
sting I'm on the air I mean no one
thinks that you're doing it for
right do you know everybody listens to
you guys do you think these guys on
Grindr listen someone goes on Grindr
someone goes on Grindr yes hey I know
that guy he's a comic I mean it's a shot
in the dark
yeah it's actually they wouldn't [ __ ]
I was gonna say that wouldn't even have
it on the Comedy Central website the
joke somebody sees sister doesn't listen
to going oh that's [ __ ] voice what's
he doing on here under a fake name
that's why yeah I mean take it off it's
ready take it off you think everybody
put your real name huh
we took it off I'm going to Grindr right
now it's off man
you're 100% yeah I can't [ __ ] I gotta
go
what's wrong rich are we going I I can't
do this anymore
can't do what comedy oh yeah we've known
that for a while what can't you do
what's wrong you're wearing three
diamond rings - now wait your hand
that's a wedding ring it's a diamond
ring are there diamonds in the wedding
ring yeah kind of Rolly Jim was right
you're falling upon Italy I'm not
falling apart no please you have think
that's funny it's funny with everybody
else it's funny if it was someone else
that's why we thought it was funny cuz
it wasn't us
yeah there's somebody else and yes sure
if that was you cuz you look like you
should be on there so do you
that's why we put you on no you got a
request within five seconds of being on
there but you are a natural to Grindr a
request the guy for fisting I guarantee
he's probably [ __ ] of fatty like a
fat guy know a fatty in his [ __ ] yes
I didn't have a comeback that's okay
yeah of course it's funny no take it
down it's already down I don't know that
right